herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich bin ich zusammen und hier unten
steht meine neue nintendo switch wir
haben beide einen von den gläubigern in
der hand und wir werden heute 12
pflichtspielen verspätung zu mir immer
im stehen und wir stehen uns gegenüber
gucken und almhütten glück wie entweder
beim boxen und ging dann zu schauen
leute wir drücken auf den breit ausgeben
gegenüber und versucht schnell anderer
gegner zu schlagen
[Musik]
gerade gerade hat
wir haben die spieler zum allerersten
mal gespielt beziehungsweise ausgepackt
ich glaub ich hilfe möglich ab auch für
schmiergelder gekocht das spiel richtig
gut aber das andere ist einfach bis
jetzt kein geld lösung wie mich die
anderen drei sekunden kleines update an
der stelle waren und nur sieben spieler
aber wir haben bei luca im video noch
die restlichen 21 freigeschaltet also
alles was ich sage von wegen es sind nur
sieben spiele und das teamspiel doch
echt wenig sinn für das geld könnt ihr
also quasi wieder vergessen oder einfach
überhören weil wir haben halt später
herausgefunden dass es noch mehr sind
machen wir weiter meine damen und herren
und war dass mindestens zwei piloten
probieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe leute glauben dass einmal das
beste spiel aller zeiten wenn ihr davon
noch künftig weiterhin leichter machen
wir weiter mit dem nächsten spiel meine
damen und herren war
doch die liste gemacht werden
[Musik]
ich glaube jetzt gewinnt die 1000 punkte
auf gewinnen
[Musik]
und da ist also spätestens jetzt mit
video einfach nur noch auf damit ihr
euch über uns einfach so lange gedauert
wir machen noch mal und noch mal
[Musik]
walter mayer schloss
er trägt früchte ich bin nicht alles an
oder bringen würde ich sagen dass das
geld für dieses spiel gut investiert war
nein erhöht der grünen zu haben was aus
diesem spiel will in hannover eine ganz
kurze fragen weil die briten konsole auf
das hinterteil vier spieler brauchen
oder 5 1 wäre es gut gespielt aber es
soll doch ich gut sein und der es ist
glaube ich also wenn er wie ein zwilling
bin ich etwa hälfte mit ihren worten
auch nur gedacht nicht gespielte szene
die restlichen spiele zugreifen kann